Oh like the shot looks so casual just so
chill you wouldn't see the reality of
this what is this what there's an
avocado that I took a bite out of some
cold soup that I'm eating with a fork
cause it's called grace gets ready to go
on book tour the vignette this look also
runs the fine line of like oh that's
like a cool chill girl to Gary Busey
highlight Fixodent
that feels right are you watching this
video we're just Monday February 1st the
day before Grayson style they aren't
pretending you have it my new style guy
comes out for me right now in a Saturday
January 30th in the morning
approximately 112 a.m. the night before
I'm about to get on a plane to start
this book tour I'm not freaking out calm
people can eat soup with a fork - OH
something got stuck in my throat and I
couldn't tell it was kale or quinoa said
the girl no one was friends with I
really am so excited for Grayson style
to come out I know I've been talking
about it so much
but it would be weird if I wasn't acting
about so today I thought I would comment
on your comments but I would comment on
the comments that had something to do
with the book oh this girl wrote a style
guide and we think Donald Trump running
for president is weird yes we do let's
start over on Tori yes that Jeff new
person to person new person probably
don't know what a new person comments on
one of my social media platforms i grace
the crap out of them and welcome them to
the grace Helbig family no touching in
this family yes that just were like yes
that jess jesse count that's the person
that I thought I saw eating the sour
cream of the grocery store but it wasn't
it was a ferret someone brought their
ferret into the grocery store how weird
is that Gilson it's getting out of hand
you my boy I was hoping I'll get you
read hashtag grace in the style by grace
Helbig tonight but it hasn't come in yet
so I guess I'll do my taxes instead my
takeaway is that you want to read my
book only just above doing your taxes so
wow thank you
taxes are one of the most stylish things
that you can do for yourself as an adult
to stay on the legal side of trends you
Charlene see new person to person new
person charlie
see more like shyly and see you Shh it's
on the brach sub telling me I have a dog
I don't have a dog I did have a ferret
but I lost it in the grocery store we
both know that stop making this weirder
than it already is
Gruber grace a grace Helbig is that me
as a sloth reading Grace and style the
art of pretending you have it or is it
Donald Trump banning books from America
hard to say no one knows both of those
could be a very strong reality ah
cash a 24 new person to person to person
a shochet 24 more like cash a 24 minutes
ago you said you were leaving and you've
just been sitting nude like in all the
cookies goober wish I just bought my
tickets to meet grace Helbig I'm a just
just myself that I'm okay with that
charts or trends your pants is a classic
now let's go to Facebook I have a
Facebook page can you guys believe it
yeah you probably can like this looks
like someone that would have a Facebook
page Gary Morton new person to person to
person Kati Morton more like are you
related to the Mortons fisherman that
guy looks like he's naked under that
rain jacket is it a Morton Morton Morton
fisherman oh I'm thinking of Gordon
Gordon fisherman you're the great can't
wait to read it
Oh Katie if you guys don't know Katie's
got a really amazing YouTube channel she
is a licensed what is it Jill licensed
marriage & Family Therapist and she has
a youtube channel that focuses on the
mental health and she is just a lovely
lovely human being so I highly recommend
going over and checking her out take me
seriously
Karl Hoffman new person to person to
person call Hoffman more like Carl huh
man you're here you were great you are a
very creative writer
I read your excerpt and could see it
made into a cartoon or movie of some
sort I ordered your book on the first
day available and bought four copies of
your last book you are a very succinct
person with your words thank you for
being so supportive that's really great
of you for those of you that don't know
Aurel is referencing the sweatpant
Diaries which are part of grace and
style and I uploaded excerpts of them to
my Wattpad page Wattpad calm
grace helbig for people to read before
the book comes out go over to Wattpad
calm such grace helbig go read those
excerpts it's diary entries written by a
pair of short pants that gets accepted
to her dream school the Mall of America
yep and I'm really proud of them
Richard J McKay to person to person
person mr. Jim McKay more like Richard J
at McKinley cow can do by grace I have
no style that is not true I find that
difficult to believe anyone and anything
can have style Kanye West
he created shoes called Yeezys Yeezy
sounds like an infection that babies get
on their butthole so I believe in you
that's gonna YouTube
Erica dowdy new person to person to
person Erica dowdy more like Erica dowdy
my ability to write a book and Gracie
wrote two of I hate everything that's
happening in this moment supercruise
plug that book girl debit Leroy Brown
new person to person to person Leroy
Brown more like Leroy
Hajin Pam Cuban Gorge is it just me or
does she look like Michael Jackson
apparently it's not just you because
this is not the first time I've gotten
this comment why does grace kind of look
like Michael Jackson in this video okay
so this is a new development and truly I
don't know how to take that though I'll
just speak with a slightly higher
register and move forward not dwelling
too much in thought over whether that is
a good thing or bad thing and perhaps I
need to learn to apply my makeup
differently or style my hair differently
let's skip that didn't help talking and
a higher register okay guys that's it
for commenting on your comments today I
hope that you had fun here with me and I
hope that if you have any thoughts or
curiosity about this book that you buy
it it's available at grey style book
calm and in bookstores everywhere I
don't know if that's true that's just a
hope I think there's something in this
book for everyone and I put a lot of
myself in this book more so than I think
I've ever put myself out there before
and that's terrifying
and exciting oh I don't know wait for
that plane to go by I wonder where
they're going